نعم انطلقت المسيره الخضراء قبل اقل من 10
دقائق من الان الساعه 1:00 بالتوقيت توقيت
الرياض وتوقيت الدوحه وكما نشاهد الاخضر
في كل مكان وهناك حمام وهناك جمهور كبير
يستعد هذه المباراه التي ستقام هنا في هذا
ستاد مدينه المدينه الاعلاميه او دوكيشن
سيتي هنا في الدوحه والتي ستنطلق وبين
بولندا والسعوديه طبعا وهناك حماس كبير
الكثير اذا اخذنا الكاميرا
وكيف يواجه الجمهور والجمهور دائما هنا
مستعد يعني ما توقعت احمد يوصل الى منطقه
استاد طب ثلاث ساعات من قيام المباراه
ولكنهم ما زال متحمسين شكرا هذا العالم
السعودي وهم دائما متحمسون اذا كان معنا
مجال احمد من اي منطقه
صباحا عن طريق معبر سلوى ولا عن طريق
عن طريق معبر ثروه الكثير على فكره احمد
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه الى هذا ستاد
تحديدا من معبر سلوى هناك حشود على هذا
المعبر التي تستمر الوفود او المشجعين
السعوديين يصلون الى هذه المنطقه وشاهدنا
يعني الحماس والفرح في وجوههم انظروا الى
هذا الشاب شو اسمك حسن من جده حسن من جده
انت كيف وصلت انا جيت والله عن طريق
الطيران متى صباح مباراه الارجنتين اول
مباراه اليوم ان شاء الله
اخر شوطه وتق- شو توقعاتكم العدد كلمه
كلمه سيدي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد
بن سلمان
[تصفيق]
اسلام واليوم نحن بملحمه عربيه اسلاميه
قويه بعيد عن كل انواع كره القدم اليوم
نعيش اسره واحده بعد فوز السعوديه اكتشفنا
ان العرب والمسلمين قلبه واحد وان شاء
الله قدامه
ولكن شكرا محمد عفوا نشاهد كذلك الفوز
الكثير من الاتحاد الكثير منهم يتحدث عن
فوز عربي في ارض عربيه وهذا مهم جدا وهناك
الحماس الكبير من الشباب الذين اتوا من
جميع مناطق المملكه من جميع الطرق يعني
ليس فقط عن طريق مطار حمد ولكن عن طريق
معبر سلوى وهناك مناطق اخرى من المنطقه
الشرقيه شاهد اشخاص قبل قليل يعني اذا
برده
وصلت اول امس
ووو وكيف شايف الاجواء كيف الاجواء رائعه
والتنظيم رائع وكل شيء في البطوله رائع
صراحه توقعاتي 1-0 السعوديه باذن الله
فرحتاه اليوم اوه هذه التوقعات هنا ومزاج
يعني من جميع الاعمار اذا شفنا هذا الطفل
جوليا جي 6
[موسيقى]
موجود في المباراه
ثعلب الدوسريعه يا صالح صالح الشبيبه وبس
والله يا صالح بوم
عندنا طبعا بعد ما نحنا وصلنا قبل ساعات
كمان مره احمد على الدوحه ولكن كما نشاهد
يعني الحماس الفرح بعيون المشجعين وكلهم
يريدون طبعا اتكلمون عن السعوديه
انت يا ولد ايه الورقه في سجور طبعا نشكر
اسمه همم
سمو ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان على تخفيف
الحمل والكلمه اللي اثرت في اللعيبه كل ما
يعني كلمتين بسيطه خففت عليهم شيء كبير
الحمد لله سعودي
[ضحك]
كثيره وما زالت الحافلات تصل اذا شاهدنا
في عمق الصوره همم ممكن نشوف انه الحافله
اتصل الى هذه المنطقه وهم في طريقهم الى
استاد تخيل لما اتوقع احمد بصراحه ان يصل
هذه الحشود بهذه الكميات او هذه هذه العدد
من الاشخاص مبكرا معك كل ذلك
المنتخب السعودي وان تكون الفرح دائما
سعوديه وعربيه بهذا القدر شكرا لك من
الدوحه وانت معنا مفرد العربيه ياريت
تحياتي ليثق فيك شكرا